I was lucky enough to have a lot of work
you know and and I'm a firm believer is
what's for you is for you Michael B
Jordan gets candid about his split from
from Lee Harvey as sets the record
straight about whether he's swiping
through the dating apps being alone wolf
is yes that that's easy for him the
actor sat down with Gail King on CBS
mornings Wednesday and opened up about
how he navigated the end of his high
profile relationship coming out of you
know that situation not to give it you
know any energy and kind of move move
from that is you know it was an
experience for me to grow you know and
learn Michael and Lori started dating
back in November 2020. what does Michael
B Jordan find very sexy a nice smile and
a laugh and a sense of humor is uh is
really sexy to me well I see why you
found who you found then because she has
all of those all of those things
absolutely actually very funny a lot of
people don't know that about it yeah
it's just really funny yeah Michael even
had the approval of her famous Dad Steve
Harvey this guy is is not a
representative
he is genuinely who he who he looks like
he is
and he's a uh he's
I mean like it threw me off at first
because he was so kind you know I figure
okay this is the game right right but it
wasn't man this dude was sincere
and he's proven to be a really really
good good guy man I'm I'm I'm I'm
actually
I mean look I'm pulling for him you know
yeah pulling for them but the two called
it quits in June 2022 after more than a
year of dating a source at the time told
E.T they were trying to move on but
we're both heartbroken and upset now the
Creed star explains that he got through
it by focusing on all the good things he
has going on I'm in my light right now
this is my Jordan year I mean that I
know this this is this is my year
there's so much going on so many
blessings so many great things this is
at a point in my career where there's
not a lot of people telling me no and
everything's wide open as for that joke
he made about being on the exclusive
dating app Raya while hosting Saturday
Night Live last month most people after
a breakup are like I'm gonna get in
better shape but I was already in Creed
shape so I had to be like all right I
guess I'll learn a new language anyway
estoy and Raya
I was joking you were joking send them
my way it's okay and while Michael
credits work with helping him get over
heartbreak he also has the support of
his Creed 3 co-star Jonathan Majors who
dished on their friendship to E.T
earlier this week we have a very amical
relationship that's my best buddy he
shows up for you my homie I mean yeah
yeah we spoke today we support each
other on the day-to-day so if it's
marvelous Marvel that day if it's uh
girl trouble this girl troubles that day
you know if it's whatever whatever you
know being so he's my brother
[Music]